bueno el área fue desarrollándose
en un ámbito convencional con lo cual lo
que se está viendo es que está esta
actitud inicial agresiva de putin y de
rusia
encontramos una resistencia inesperada
en el pueblo de ucrania y una
resistencia inesperada también en la
comunidad internacional que deploró de
una manera muy directa toda esta acción
agresiva o sea que si tenemos que hacer
un balance en este momento es
verdaderamente
positivo dentro de lo que es la
situación de triste de una guerra y
sobre todo porque esto ha servido como
un catalizador de la habitual decisiva
de rusia un catalizador para para
diseminar la comunidad internacional
para respuesta a este tipo de agresiones
no nos olvidemos que estamos saliendo
una pandemia que ha azotado a todos los
países y entonces el mundo ha demostrado
claramente
desde la resolución de
la asamblea general de las naciones
unidas
desde los sistemas de sanciones desde
las actitudes de todos los países o de
la gran mayoría
se puede alcanzar entonces la paz por la
vía diplomática e irma teniendo en
cuenta estas conversaciones que
siguieron a cabo entre ucrania y rusia
en belarús realmente esto es posible
porque muchos también dicen que puede
ser como una farsa o para ganar un poco
de tiempo entre las partes para
reorganizarse y pensar cómo seguir esta
guerra como lo de usted
bueno yo tenemos que justamente por lo
que comentaba anteriormente
a putin no le están saliendo las cosas
como las tenía la revista inicialmente
es decir una animación rápida colocar o
sea derrocar por supuesto al presidente
de ucrania y poner un gobierno activo
todo esto no ha salido como como estaba
previsto pero también es cierto que en
realidad esto esto tiene un origen
anterior y es la paranoia de luz y aire
putin especialmente como autócrata
respecto de lo que se llama la no
garantía de seguridad para revocar por
parte de la otan y de eeuu esencialmente
entonces acá se juegan una serie de
elementos que habrá que ver cómo se
desenvuelven ahora va a haber nuevas
conversaciones
frontera con polonia
pero bueno todo esto está en pleno
desarrollo y es algo que vamos a ir
observando con el tiempo por supuesto
que tenemos que considerar que algunos
sanz a ser actores internacionales y en
particular los agresores muchas veces no
entran dentro de un análisis de
racionalidad absoluta claro tonces
también son muy peligrosas se les dio
sentido porque pueden escalar hacia
hacia lugares no deseados e incluso no
eran deseados inicialmente por los
agresores pero que después que no se
pueden volver a personas como quedan
siempre una salida hacia adelante es una
salida de la armadora para poder ir más
y en este orden de ideas se puede
realmente empeorar este conflicto como
lo dicen los franceses
como si en este orden de días que estaba
diciendo que esta guerra se puede
escalar le quiero preguntar si es
posible entonces un empeoramiento de
todo este conflicto como lo afirmó el
ministro francés de exteriores
bueno en realidad puede empeorarse con
una piel sitiada con con el hecho de que
se estacione y que vamos a aclarar que
rusia tiene
muchos más recursos militares de lo que
está empleando en esta guerra con lo
cual también yo creo que la guerra esta
guerra es una de las tres guerras que se
está librando por visitar llorarlo la
guerra militar bien el terreno la guerra
de la información y la ciberguerra son
las tres guerras que se están librando
en estos momentos entonces putin o
empleados todos los recursos que tienen
y esto muestra que están planteando un
juego estratégico todo esto empieza en
diciembre
cuando putin propone un acuerdo con la
otan y un tratado con eeuu para tratar
de que estas estas dos organizaciones y
eeuu le den ciertas días de seguridad en
realidad lo que quedará en ese sentido
que la otan es una alianza
disuasiva defensiva y no agresiva y eeuu
también no nuestra posición intención ni
por el frente interno ni por el
desenvolvimiento de otros conflictos
anteriores de agredirla rusia y eso es
lo que ha recogido la comunidad
internacional rhenus en todo en las
sanciones en la resolución de la
asamblea general de las naciones unidas
a caer y no sólo agresor soy que lucila
con
poquísimos aliado bielorrusia porque
fíjate que hasta china y has tenido
quiera también pretendo un expansionismo
global pero por otro medio por los
medios comerciales a través de la ruta
de la seda es decir no quiere entrar en
un conflicto armado y entrar en un
conflicto armado solamente la
locura o la irracionalidad de un
autócrata puedes llevar a la guerra a
una verdad es perdida a una situación
también se habló de la posibilidad de
arma nuclear esto de gusto de arma
nuclear
todas las cuestiones que harían una
escalada imparable